TIMOTHY JORDAN: Hello.
AUDIENCE: Hello.
AUDIENCE: Hey.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: How are you?
AUDIENCE: I'm fine.
How are you?
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Thanks, Will.
I'm good, too.
Thanks for asking.
So you're here for the
Getting Started with
Google History talk.
I hope that you are.
If you're not, and you just
wandered in here, well, good.
I think you'll have fun, too.
I'm Timothy Jordan.
I'm going to be your developer
advocate for the next hour.
And it can be afterwards, too.
Join me online on Google+.
You can get there by going
to timothyjordan.com/+.
So let's just dive right in.
One of my favorite features on
Google+ is Instant Upload.
It's cool because I just take
photos on my phone, they're
automatically uploaded
in the background.
But then when I get to Google+,
I can look at my
photos, and I can choose when
to share them and with who.
And this distinction is pretty
cool, and I think really
important is that I don't
just share everything.
I get a private space for all
of my photos, and I can go
back and look at them
whenever I want to.
But the ones that I do
want to share, I
share out with circles.
And that's where Google
History comes in.
Think about Google History as
sort of an instant upload, but
for almost everything else.
Activities that users take on
your websites can be pushed
into a private space on
Google+ called Google+
History, and then they can
optionally share them out
whenever they want.
And at the end of the day, it
really comes down to this.
Is your content in
more places?
Now let's take a look at this
in an actual product.
We've been playing around with
this for a while, and our
friends at Last.fm decided to
play along with us, which is
pretty fun.
Now, if you're not familiar with
Last.fm, they're really
great at helping you keep a
record of everything you
listen to wherever you listen
to it, and they call this
scrobbling.
And then based on
your taste, they
recommend music and concerts.
And it's a lot of fun just
listening to Last.fm.
And because of this sort of
saving of your taste, we think
it's a really good pairing
for Google+ History.
So together, we whipped up this
demo, which is-- well,
I'll take you through it.
So I'm at this page, and you
can tell that it's a test
page, an example page, if you
will, because we are in early
developer preview.
But there's a sign-in
button right there.
I'm going to click on the Sign
In button, and I get a
permissions dialogue.
Now, the user, when they grant
access are granting access to
their Google+ ID, and the
ability for Last.fm to save
activity to their
Google+ History.
So I'll go ahead and
click Connect here.
And there we go.
I've now connected my
Last.fm account
with my Google+ account.
I'm going to take a jaunt over
here to the radio and listen
to a track.
Now, my friend Adai, who is just
over there in the hat,
was telling me about
this band.
And I think I'll
check them out.
Stereo 360.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Let me just turn this
down a little bit.
We'll listen to that in the
background while we keep
going, shall we?
Now, I'm listening to a radio
station as I do on
Last.fm all the time.
The one difference here is
that in the background,
Last.fm is communicating to
Google, writing moments about
what I listen to.
Let's actually take a look at
that in Google+ History.
So this is my History tab.
This is, again, an early
developer preview.
This is the developer UI.
So you're going to see moments
there, and you'll have the
ability to share them to make
sure that this whole flow is
working for you.
I'm going to reload the page.
And you see right there at the
top is the Last.fm moment.
[SOME CLAPPING]
It's a demo.
It works.
That's cool.
So in that moment, let me just
point out a couple things.
You see the album art right
there at the top.
And then on the bottom you see
Last.fm's logo, and you see a
link to the song on Last.fm.
We'll just open that in a new
tab, so you can see what that
looks like.
This is the song page
on Last.fm linked
right from your moment.
So this is the area where the
user can go back and look at
all the things that they've
been listening to--
I'll go ahead and stop the
song at this point.
They can look at all the things
that they've been
listening to in the past day,
week, month, for as long as
they've had their account
connected.
It's really neat, right?
The next step they can take is
to share this out with their
friends, and they get
to do this with
the power of circles.
Which means I can share this
with my friend, Adai, and, if
I want, no one else.
Or I can share it with public,
or I can share it with my
music friends.
Click Share there, and
let's take a look at
that post on my profile.
And you can see, again,
we have the album art.
We have the link back
to the song.
We also have attribution
listened to on Last.fm.
So that's Google+ History.
Now, I want to take you through,
in this session,
step-by-step how to do this on
your website, and I think
you'll find that it's really
straightforward.
We're going to first look
at how to set up your
application.
You're going to tell Google that
you want to develop for
Google+ History.
The next step is to authorize
your user.
And that's when we saw that
permissions dialogue pop up
and the user said yes.
And then finally,
write moments.
And these are technologies that
you're almost certainly
already familiar with.
First off, who's heard about the
API console while you've
been at Google I/O?
Yeah?
We use this for all
of our APIs.
You register your application
there, and you add API
services to it.
Who's used OAuth2?
Great.
Essentially everyone.
And who's used a RESTful API?
There you go.
So let's set up this
application.
There's just a few steps.
First off, you sign up for
the developer preview.
Now again, this is an early
developer preview.
It's meant for developers
only.
It's not ready for
your end users.
But it is the right time to test
it on your application
and give us feedback.
Next, you enable the
history API.
So you're going to create
an application
in the API's console.
And you're going to go to the
services tab and turn on both
the Google+ API and the
Google+ history API.
And then finally, you're going
to create an OAuth2 client ID,
and that's what we use
in our application.
So to sign up for the developer
preview, head over
to this URL.
It's our developer site,
/+/history/preview.
Enter in your email
that's associated
with the Google account.
Now when you use this Google
account to create an
application in the API's
console, you'll have the
ability to turn on
the history API.
And when you use this same
account in Google+, you'll be
able to see the developer
UI we have there.
If additional developers on your
team need access and need
to test, they need to sign up
their accounts as well.
As long as they're logged in,
everything will work.
Then we're going to enable
the Google history API.
And finally create an
OAuth2 client ID.
And this is so easy.
I'm just going to
do it right now.
So here I am in the
API's console.
I'm going to create
a new project.
In this case I'm going
to call it--
oh, I don't know--
hi mom.
And we're going to scroll
all the way
down till we see Google+.
There we're going to enable
Google+ API, and the Google+
history API.
Now this is not the first time
I've turned on these services.
If it was I'd be presented
with some API terms of
service, quickly read through,
make sure that I was going to
comply with all of those,
and agree to them.
So we've created the
application, we've turned on
these services.
The next step is to create
an OAuth2 client ID.
So we click over to API Access,
and you'll notice this
really big button that says
exactly what I did.
When we click on that,
we're going to name
this product, hi mom--
she's going to be so happy.
Click on Next.
It's going to make a web
application, and I'm going to
put in my URL here.
Now this is going to make
it easier, if I use
the right URL here.
My URL is example.com.
Yours is probably going
to be different.
And we select the right
protocol, HTTPS, which I'd
recommend, or the insecure
version if you need to.
We're going to create
this client ID.
A couple things to
note about this.
So we have this client ID right
there, and we have an
email address, and
a client secret.
That's great.
We also have the redirect
URIs, and
the JavaScript origin.
Let's fill those out.
Now, if we were using the server
side flow, which I'll
talk more about, you'll need to
put in your redirect URI.
And that's where Google is going
to redirect the user
flow right after they agree to
those permissions in that
permissions dialogue box.
You put in all the possible
redirect URIs that you might
use, and then you're going
to specify that in your
application as well.
Google will do a match.
If it doesn't match, it's
not going to work.
And then the JavaScript
origin.
This is especially important
if you're going to use
authentication through
JavaScript, or you're going to
use our sign-in button, which
is, again, with JavaScript.
The JavaScript origin needs
to be two things.
One, your domain, including the
right protocol and port.
So it matters if it's HTTPS
versus HTTP, and,
of course, the port.
It's probably going to be 80
unless you're testing on a
staging server.
It needs to be that
particular port.
Also, you're going to add a
special origin for the button.
And this is just early in
the testing period.
And I'll talk more about the
button in a little bit.
So let's assume that I added
those, and then we
use this client ID.
And I'll tell you where
to do that.
That's setting up our
application, and the next step
is to authorize the user.
I made a flow chart.
So we start out by initiating
the OAuth flow.
Now we've done this, if you've
worked with OAuth2, lots of
times before and lots of ways.
But I'm going to show you a
really easy way to do it.
Then we get to permissions
dialogue.
That's on the user.
They just say yes.
Then we have either a client
side or a server side flow.
I'm going to talk about each,
and then we're done.
So for initiating the OAuth
flow, we put together this
little button.
Just a real quick question.
Again, who's used OAuth2?
Let me see those hands, and
just leave them up.
Now, put them down if
you've never had a
problem with OAuth.
Who's lying?
OK.
Put them down.
We're always looking for ways
to make OAuth easier to use,
and one of the most difficult
things is just
starting the flow.
And we have client libraries
to make this
really easy for you.
But we thought we'd put together
a button, too.
And it has a couple
advantages.
One, all you have to do is add
some attributes, and you've
got the button to initiate the
OAuth flow on your page and
configured properly.
The other thing is that it's
going to look common, so
people who see this will
recognize this button.
It's just like the
plus one button.
You all use the plus one
button itself, because
whenever a user lands on your
page they know exactly what it
is and what it's going
to do for them.
Now, adding the button to your
page is really similar to
using the plus one button.
You include the script at the
top, so the same script for
the plus one button, and then
you add one of these tags.
Now I'm showing a sample
configuration for both the
client side and the
server side flow.
The client side flow just has
a couple fewer attributes.
For example, it doesn't have the
redirect URI or the state.
Both of those are required for
the server side flow, but not
for client side.
Let's go through those
attributes.
First off, we have action, and
this just specifies what the
button's going to be.
It's easy.
It has to be connect.
Add action equals connect,
and you'll get
this particular button.
The client ID.
We saw that when we set
up our application.
Copy and paste that in here.
The redirect URI.
If you're using the server side
flow, this is where you
want the users to go
after they consent.
You're just going to do a
couple of quick things.
The user will likely not even
see the page fully rendered
before it redirects back
to your application.
The state.
Now this is for your own
verification, and it's an
important security step.
When you're doing the server
side flow, you're going to set
a state variable.
It doesn't matter what it is,
as long as it's unique and
non-guessable.
You set that state variable
at the beginning, and
you check it later.
If it's the same, you're good.
If it's not the same, somebody's
trying to attack
you, and that will be bad.
The callback.
This button has a callback.
So when the user gets back to
the page and everything's
done, you can call a function
on that page.
And this is where you're going
to hide the button, show other
elements, pat them on the back,
that kind of thing.
And then scope.
By default, this button will
use the plus.me scope.
Now that will give you access
to the user's Google+ ID.
You need an additional
scope, which is the
plus.moments.write scope, to
actually write moments into
the History API.
So that's initiating
the OAuth flow.
Permissions dialog, again,
looks like this.
And now, we've got client side
and server side flows.
Let's start with the
client side.
It's really easy.
The client side flow will give
you an access token that will
last for 60 minutes.
It's non-renewable, so you
cannot refresh this token.
So you have access to write
moments while the user's on
your website.
Now once the user's gone through
the flow, it'll call
the callback that you specified
on the button, and
you want to use this to both
hide the button so they don't
click it again and go
through again--
you want to give them feedback
that they're done, and handle
any error messages.
Now, I go through, in detail,
error messages in the advanced
section that's at the
end of the day.
I hope you can come
to that as well.
Just a preview of that is, the
one that you really want to
make sure to handle is if the
user doesn't give you
authorization.
If they don't authorize, you're
going to want to handle
that in a special way, like ask
them why, or tell them to
try again, or explain what
you're trying to do here.
Now, for the server side there
are a few more steps.
Server side gives you a
little bit more, too.
With the server side, you get
that token the lasts for 60
minutes, but you can renew it.
So you can submit moments when
the user is not currently on
your website.
And this is really cool if,
let's say, I purchased
something and I want to write
a moment for when it's
shipping to the users in their
history, and they see that
this new product is
coming to them.
Well the user's not going to
be on the website at that
time, so you will need to have
done the server side flow.
And we think, in fact, for most
cases you want to do the
server side flow.
And the flow looks like this.
Once you hit that
redirect URI--
Google will call that
you're going to get a code and
a state via GET params.
Verify the state.
This is the one that you made
up, that's unique and
non-guessable.
And then send that code to
Google in exchange for
credentials.
Store those user's credentials,
and then you're
going to output a page that
just calls one method,
gapi.connect.complete.
You're going to pass it the
credentials, and it will close
that redirect URI.
Then when the user goes back
to the original web page,
it'll make sure that that
callback gets called.
If you don't call
gapi.connect.complete, then we
don't know that the flow has
been fully completed, and that
callback may not be called.
This is what it looks
like in code.
Step one is right up
there at the top.
We get the code and the state.
And in step two, we're going
to verify that the state is
what we expect.
And we're going to store
the credentials
under step three there.
I'm sorry.
Three is exchanging
the credentials.
And then four is storing them.
And then five, we're just going
to output that web page.
Passing it the credentials so
it can put those into the
gapi.connect.complete
function.
And then this is what that
page looks like.
You see we're calling
gapi.connect.complete, and
we're putting in there the ID
token and the access token.
So that's the client side and
the server side flow, at which
point we're done.
Next step.
Writing moments.
The writing moments is all about
getting the activity on
the left there to be a
moment on the right
there in Google+ History.
So you can see, and as you saw
in the demo earlier, is the
radio station.
And we are writing that moment
into Google+, and it becomes a
moment there.
And the flow looks a little
bit like this.
And there's two steps here.
First, we write that moment.
The next step is that Google
is going to go out to that
target URL, retrieve that
page, and learn
something about it.
And what it learns it's going to
use to render that moment,
and it's going to use to render
the post if the user
decides to share.
Let's start with
the write step.
These are the different
activity types.
It's a pretty short list.
This is what we're
starting with.
And one of the things that we
definitely want feedback on is
what are the activity types
that are missing that are
essential to you and
your website.
And in fact, if you go to our
documentation, we have an
issue tracker where you can
submit moment types.
Now, each of these activities
is going to be
encapsulated in JSON.
That's the payload that
you're going to
transmit in RESTful request.
And essentially this is a
JSONified schema.org markup.
We're looking for a
type, a target,
and sometimes a result.
Now, the type is the activity
type that is taken.
This could be a comment, or it
could be a listen activity, it
could be a buy activity.
And that's just going to be
a URL that identifies it.
Next, the target.
This is the item that
was acted upon.
So if I listen to something,
this is the song.
If I bought something,
this is a product.
And the result is any resulting
data from that action.
So if I made a comment,
this is the comment.
This includes the comment
permalink,
and the comment text.
In code it looks like this.
This is a listen activity.
And in the JSON there you'll see
the type listen activity,
and then you'll see a target
URL, which is actually the
link to this song.
Really simple.
The next one, comment activity,
and there's a little
bit more to this.
We have the type at the top.
It's a comment activity.
And then we have the blog post
that we commented on under
target URL.
This third section, result, is
the comment that we wrote.
It's of type comments.
There's a URL to the
permalink for the
comment, and we have text.
This is the text
of the comment.
So that's step one, writing
a moment to Google.
Step two, fetching
the target URL.
And again, it's about this.
It's about rendering the moment
and rendering the post
if the user shares.
We get the image, and the title,
and whatever else we
can show in the moment to make
it rich from schema.org markup
on the page.
Now, who is familiar with
microdata markup?
Great.
Keep those hands up.
Who is familiar with schema.org,
like how it works?
It's the same set.
That's what I'm trying to say.
Lower your hands.
Schema.org is microdata
markup.
The difference is the URL that
defines the type and the
different properties
that are available.
For these we're looking
for this.
We're looking for a type, a
name, a URL, a description,
and any number of other
properties as per each
particular type.
Now, some of these are going
to be required, and some of
these are going to
be recommended.
And we have a full listing of
that in our documentation.
But in general, you should
almost always include the
type, the name, the description,
and the image.
Type is always going
to be required.
The name, the description and
image are what allow us, when
a user just shares a URL in
Google+, to render that
snippet in the post.
And it's also good practice
for your website.
Remember, schema.org is markup
for the web page that's been
adopted by Yahoo!,
Bing, and Google.
And it's the way that you get
to tell these search engines
what the item is on
your web page.
Because there's more to a web
page than just the page.
And schema.org is
how you add that
intelligence into the markup.
Now, if we want to take a look
at this in an actual page,
it's going to look like this.
This is just HTML with some
added attributes.
That's the microdata markup, and
we highlight them for you.
The key take away from this
slide is that you'll notice
all of this data is encapsulated
in the tag.
So whether the page has the
markup or doesn't have the
markup, it looks the
same to your user.
And in fact, you don't have to
add any content to your page
to get this markup.
Dollars to doughnuts,
you already have
all the data there.
You just need to tell us
what each item is.
So going through from the top,
you'll see an item scope and
an item type.
Now, those are going to
be on the parent tag.
All the item props below
that are going to be
included in this item.
Now the item type specifies
what it is.
Now in there you'll see the item
props, and each of those
has a value that specifies
what property that we're
indicating here.
Now the property could be
a description, an image.
And you'll even notice we have
a sub item here called In
Album, because schema.org
is hierarchical.
You can make an In Album
of a music recording.
And that's pretty much it.
So again, to markup your page,
what you're going to want to
do is look at schema.org
markup, and look at our
activity pages to make sure that
you're including at least
the required fields.
And I would recommend the
recommended fields.
And that's it.
We've set up our application
using the API console.
We've authorized the
user using OAuth2.
And then we've written
moments.
And by writing these moments
into Google, we also give
Google the target URL.
Google goes out, finds out
about that web page, and
renders this moment for the user
in a rich way in Google+.
And it was using technologies
that we're all familiar with,
which is pretty cool.
That's all there is to actually
setting up Google+ History.
But what it can do for your
website and what we think it
can do for users is
so much more.
This idea of the user being
able to save all of their
activity on the web privately
into Google+, and then
optionally share whatever they
want to share with their
friends, their family,
or public.
I think this ability's going
to be really cool.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
That's my favorite part.
No, I'm kidding.
So it's a really easy
API to use.
We have two additional
sessions.
An advance where I go into
some detail about each of
these things, and we do some
cool things with the button
and the API.
And we also have a code lab
as well, and I've thrown a
permalink up there to the
Google+ session track.
So if you want to check out
those sessions and come,
please follow that URL.
Now, again, simple API, quick
presentation, time for questions.
Please ask me any questions
that you may have.
And if you want, and you're nice
to me, I'll give you a
sticker, too.
What's up?
AUDIENCE: With the understanding
that this is the
developers preview, I noticed
that one of the things that's
common to all of the types is
that they require a reference
back to your website to fetch
the snippet information.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Any possibility that
that's going to be removed in
the future for, again,
using the
comparison to instant uploads.
When you instantly upload a
photo, there's no reference
back to a picture on
some other website.
So is there a way to just store
content on Google's server?
TIMOTHY JORDAN: It's a great
question, and I actually think
there's another question
in there, too, for
the use case of mobile.
There's the image
that you create.
And most the time if you have
a website and you have an
application, that image is
going to exist somewhere.
And in fact, for creating an
image and it exists somewhere,
you would use create activity.
And you can link to that.
However, if you're doing an
activity that doesn't leave a
trail on the internet-- so you
don't have an URI or a URL
that we can go out and fetch
in the created activity--
we're working on a solution
for just that problem.
AUDIENCE: OK, great.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: So look
for that during
this developer preview.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: I noticed that it
adds a moment to their
account, but then they have to
manually go through and share
that moment.
Is there any plans for having
people give the options for
auto-sharing it in the future?
TIMOTHY JORDAN: So I recommend
that you play with the UI.
I mean there is a way to sort of
make some of those moments
visible on your moments tab.
And that's pretty interesting.
But there is no way for
something to be automatically
shared to your circles
when you make an
activity somewhere else.
And I think that's the key thing
about History that I
think is really cool is that I
want everything in one place
just for me.
But there's only a few things
that I want to share with my
friends and family.
And almost always, for me
personally, it's never
consistent.
Like when I book some travel
and I take some photos,
sometimes when I go on a trip
I want those photos to be
shared, and sometimes I want to
keep them just for myself,
or sometimes I want to keep
them with just my family.
There was no sort of consistent
I want this always
to be shared with everybody.
So that's what we're looking
at with Google+ History.
AUDIENCE: But there's no way
that even within our own UI we
can say yes, I want to
share this, too?
Kind of like how the plus one
button, when you click the
plus one button, it immediately
gives you a share option.
Because it seems kind of
disjointed to say OK, if you
wanted to actually share this,
go login to Google+, go over
to your Moments tab, then
manually share it.
It'd be nice if it could
be done in one flow.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Yeah.
So how would that look like in
an API form, do you think?
AUDIENCE: My hope would be that
I could pop up a share
moment right there in my--
TIMOTHY JORDAN: So you want to
write the moment and then you
also want to share in your UI?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: OK.
Please join us on the discussion
forum, and make
sure that we hear
that feedback.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Yeah.
That's a good point.
Joseph just said you
can use the share
integration on your site.
We have a sharing link.
So if you wanted to do it in
flow, you could still pop up
this JavaScript window that
allow the user to share direct
within their stream.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: So the sign-in button
you showed, is it
possible to use it with
more than one scope if
needed in any app?
Because the parameter
only said scope.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Yeah.
It's space separated scope.
So put in as many as you like.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
TIMOTHY JORDAN: So you talked
a lot about using it from a
website, obviously.
Is there stuff available, like
JARs and things, to use this
from applications, like Android
apps and things?
TIMOTHY JORDAN: I'm glad you
asked that question.
Yes.
Coming soon you will have the
ability to do this both from
iOS and Android, and I'll talk
about that in a little bit
more detailed in the
advanced session.
But also there's a session on
your schedule about mobile
specifically where they're
going to go into
some depth with that.
So please do come to that.
AUDIENCE: Great, thank you.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Is that
all for questions?
Nope.
AUDIENCE: Hey, Timothy.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Hey.
AUDIENCE: So I love microdata,
and I love activity streams.
And I know that activity streams
was used, obviously,
for the History API.
And I'm happy, and I'm sad.
I'm sad because there's
basically an overlap in
vocabulary that ends up being
confusing for both of them.
Is there an open forum where
we can discuss how to
consolidate the activity streams
specification with
schema.org?
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Great.
And are you talking specifically
about the markup
on the target URL--
AUDIENCE: I'm talking about--
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Or the JSON
that's transmitted?
AUDIENCE: --the JSON and the
microdata that I just saw.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: And at Google
we feel very strongly about
open standards and implementing
them wherever it
makes sense.
And we did have this
conversation, and we would
love to have this conversation
with you.
A great place to start that
would be with us after the
session if you want to talk in
person, or on our discussion
forum that's linked from
the documentation.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, OK.
So you guys are working with
schema.org, or are you guys
schema.org?
Because I never know who--
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Well, schema.org
is an open standard
that was adopted by all three
major search engines and a
number of other people.
And we do work closely
with them, yes.
AUDIENCE: So you are sort of
bringing the activity concepts
to schema.org?
TIMOTHY JORDAN: I'm sorry?
AUDIENCE: You are bringing
the activity concepts to
schema.org.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Oh, I see nods
in the front here, so I guess
that's a yes.
But why don't you come up and
we'll talk about this in more
detail afterwards.
AUDIENCE: OK.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Thank you.
Yeah, this is a good point.
I have Joseph and Paul.
We have a number of engineers
that have worked on the
Google+ History.
So if you do have some very
specific or technical
questions, let's come up and
have a little party.
It looks like we're ending
early, so we have some time.
Oh, one more question.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I just had a question if there
was going to be any, in the
future, the thought of allowing
apps and people to
read the user's moments, and get
a listing of the moments,
and stuff like that.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: I mean we, as
a policy, don't comment on
future features or that
kind of thing.
But I definitely want to hear
the feature requests.
So let's talk about that, and
if you can, make sure to add
it to the discussion forums
so we have it in place.
Thank you.
All right.
Thank you so much for coming.
[APPLAUSE]